the craziest thing that I've heard on
coke at 19 is that it is created by 5g
and so and and I was like that sounds
crazy to me and the the person was like
no no no you got to watch this video and
they say it's so compellingly but I was
like this doesn't sound right it's not
I've watched probably some of the same
videos it's complete crap actually
please don't believe it I mean first of
all we're getting much more radiation
naturally than 5g is giving any cell
plus the the that's not a good
correlation you know you could say oh
you know the bats of breathing so
breathing causes this you know there's a
lot of correlations you can draw so it's
not from a Wuhan lab either it's not
from a snake it's almost certainly from
a bat maybe through a Pangolin in the
spiny anteater but we can trace this
it's it's simple science we can read
nama geneticist I can read the DNA of
the virus I can see that so that so one
I've heard you say that before so I want
to understand what is a virus and what
would human fingerprints on a
manufactured virus look like so let's
not waste water viruses the virus is a
sub life-form it doesn't have all the
components to live but it's got enough
instructions that once it's inside
another species cell it can instruct
that cell to make more copies of itself
and break out and it's evolved over you
know potentially 450 million years these
corona viruses have been around for a
very long time infecting dinosaurs and
infecting all the mammals on planets so
these are ancient formidable foes but
they actually have one weakness which is
their envelope so I've said that you
shouldn't think of the virus like a
cannonball because you most people draw
it like this cannibal it's actually more
like a bubble that you can pop and
that's why washing your hands is so
simple soap will kill this thing now
what's on the outside is little proteins
that make it
prickly it's called a spike protein and
that spike is what engages with
throat and our lung cells and once it
engages it tricks the cell into taking
it inside the cell like a Trojan horse
would all right so I want to I want to
go step by step so I I've often wondered
okay if this thing gets on me can it
wiggle like do they locomote or is it
like if it hits my cheek is it gonna
crawl into my eye or is it only gonna
get there if I put my finger in my eye
like how does it work
yeah if it gets into your on your face
the only way it's gonna get into your
body is if you move it there the
announcing because the skin has dead
cells and so it can't it can't like
penetrate the layer of dead cells to get
to living tissue correct correct
so we have keratinized dead cells and
these cannot be penetrated by the virus
even if they were to get into one of
these cells they're not going to respawn
because those dead cells are not gonna
make more copies it has to be a
currently surviving living dividing
healthy cell and so the only way to get
that is either your eye you nose a mouth
or some other orifice the way to think
of this somebody described it as you
know when you get what's a glitter
glitter or sticks to everything and yes
days you you'll have glitter like that's
what the virus is like interesting okay
so that's a little scary is it as
immobile as a piece of glitter media it
will only move if I move it correct but
but that doesn't mean if it lands on the
back of your throat it's gonna stay
there right over a period of a few days
it's gonna get washed down slowly and
spread down if you're unlucky into your
lungs but it's not gonna walk there it's
gonna be carried by the fluid in your
throat that's interesting so I always
assumed that what was happening was it
was actually getting into my bloodstream
is it not doing that it gets into a what
I'll call a topical cell you probably
have a much better name for it but
something right on the surface it's
getting into that cell it's dividing and
then does is the virus somehow still
also in a position where it can be
brushed down lower Yeah right so these
are epithelial cells in our lungs
and we also have endothelial cells which
are in our blood vessels and all of
these types of these both these type of
cells have a lot of the law that the
spike protein key inserts into so they
are the most susceptible but can it get
into the blood absolutely can get into
the blood but it's easier to just wash
down into your lungs than to go via your
blood stream
but once it's in your bloodstream and
that seems to happen to a majority
patients you'll actually find that it
can inflame your gut and your heart
particularly oh and that's that's pretty
scary because if it gets to your heart
especially if you're elderly that's when
it can cause well potentially lethal
problems what are your thoughts on the
corona virus and did this come from
another like another planet
[Laughter]
we had enough viruses in our own damn
planet yeah blame and other planets just
a reminder that life evolves
opportunistically that's what natural
selection is all about and what makes
the corona virus virus particularly
diabolical it appears is not how deadly
it is but how symptom lists it can be
before you even notice you have it -
then take precautions that is ideal if
you're the virus because now you can
spread let's look at an extreme other
case let's look at cholera okay they get
this a lot in the Ganges in India okay
particularly very linked cholera will
kill you in a day or two you say oh
that's a that's a that's a deadly but
well you know it's more deadly than a
really deadly cholera rice is a less
deadly cholera virus why because no it
doesn't kill you in two days it kills
you in seven days by then you've spread
it to many more people than if you drop
dead after two days so it is possible
for an especially deadly virus to not be
as totally deadly in its full effect on
the world okay so so the corona virus
it's because you might be able to carry
it for two weeks and spread it then you
have symptoms and then then you're gonna
say let me wash my hands
you don't spread it to your whole family
and your school and buy them yeah so
that's why special attention is needed
for and special precautions are needed
so I don't think the precautions being
taken are out of line with the risk oh
yeah but I'm it's not an overt act right
I'd say though that a life lived in fear
is a life half lived if you think about
it so what you want to do is just take
precautions you know this is it's a it's
an experiment in whether people will
listen to scientists what we'd Atom
Egoyan Ocean Dragoon Jeanine show up in
door shuts honey email that again and
record her own troll adder Indonesia be
honest in time and I generally I'd say
it's an ironic if you take somebody
who's doing their best to get the world
ready and you know putting in my case
billions of dollars into these tools for
infectious diseases and really trying to
solve broadly infectious diseases
including those that can cause pandemics
but that you know we're in a crazy
situation so there's going to be crazy
rumors I hope whether it's individuals
or countries then some ways this shows
us how interdependent we are that to
stop a global pandemic we need to find
whoever's the best whatever the best
vaccine construct are the best drugs and
we need to make it without just focusing
on one country we need to make it for
the entire world including for countries
that don't have the resources to pay for
vaccine research or vaccine factories
you know they're actually many ways
should be the priority for what we do
what we did in this study was we looked
to try to figure out based on the
genetics of the virus and what we knew
about coronaviruses before this where
the virus might have come from so one
thing I can tell you is that this is not
a bioweapon nobody made this virus in
the laboratory this is a product of
nature what we believe is is that the
virus probably a long time ago
originated from
a bat species because there are
coronaviruses of bats that are very
similar to this new coronaviruses SARS
coronavirus - but there are other parts
of the virus that look more like other
animal coronaviruses so what we believe
is is that this is a recombinant so the
virus combined from two different
species to create a virus that is now
infecting humans now we don't know how
long the virus was in humans it could be
just a few months could be years could
be decades but what we do know is is
that there are a few small changes that
were made in the virus that allowed it
to spread more rapidly we know that the
origin of this virus is different than
the original SARS virus that virus was
actually a zone o'seas it's disease that
spreads from animals directly to humans
this virus definitely originated in
animals probably bats and some other
animals - you probably heard on the news
talk about this spiny anteater that has
some viruses that are similar so what we
think is is that this virus is a
recombinant it probably came from a bat
virus plus perhaps one of these viruses
from the Pangolin it recombined the
genetic material came together and then
it probably spread in humans for a while
we don't know how long it could been
months could have been decades of this
virus spreading and evolving in some
other animal or humans and then finally
just that one little mutation that
occurred that allowed it to spread more
rapidly there is a statement now I've
heard on this that this was all a
conspiracy to defeat the president
regardless of that's just nonsense do
you think that the Italians created this
what's happening Italy I think it's all
made up that's ridiculous so the Chinese
made up 80,000 their people dying and
collapsed the economy in order to affect
our President John that's not what's
happening
so people these conspiracy theories on
the left and the right are not helpful
well you can't tell people to stop doing
what they'll do it anyway but I'm just
telling you it's not helpful in it's
nonsense this is a
real problem it's a crisis it is not the
apocalypse so we have to be we can't
create public panic on the other way we
need to take the steps necessary to get
this under control and some of the stuff
is just kind of trying to convince
people of false cures if some is really
ridiculous I mean the most ridiculous
example I think that I've seen is one
saying that if you think you have
coronavirus you can drink bleach and
that will cure you which obviously it
will not and and not only will it not
but that's that's obviously extremely
dangerous and something that no one
should be doing so we want to make sure
that we take that kind of misinformation
down anything that's going to put people
in imminent risk of harm and we work
with the w-h-o it's a trusted
organization that basically can give us
a list of these debunked claims so we
can operationalize that and go out and
find them and try to take that down if
you want more advice wisdom guidance
from other successful entrepreneurs on
how you can navigate the coronavirus
situation check out the video right
there next to me I hope you find it
valuable continue to believe and I'll
see you there did you see how the
statistics on how many times we checked
our face in a day